hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another sundance 2022
interview this is a very special one
because this interview is from one of my
favorite films the festival this year
emily the criminal
hello
huge huge huge congratulations on your
movie i love it thank you thank you
so john i can't imagine how many times
you've done this already but with a
festival interview i must ask you to
give us a synopsis of your movie sure uh
so emily the criminal is about a young
woman who is in a lot of debt a lot of
student debt specifically
and uh she gradually becomes a criminal
to pay off her loans we always talked
about it as a thriller but to me
deep down it's almost like a
coming-of-age story about someone
discovering what they like to do what
they're good at and what they might
continue doing i can definitely see that
applying so
this is your
first feature and it's not easy to get a
first feature off the ground so what
would you say wound up being the key to
getting a green light whether it's your
short a person you met peace financing
that came in you name it i'll be fun
she read it and she wanted to do it and
uh she wanted to produce it as well i
think there are a lot of actors out
there who like produce movies or say
that they do but um aubry plaza actually
does she put it
under her arm like a football and just
ran it up the field
we could keep making sports metaphors
but i'll stop there
for it
who's the guy for the chiefs the
quarterback yeah he's like that threw it
down okay got your baseball metaphor to
baseball mahomes
yeah
uh
the homes emily the criminal my home
dude that's a baseball metaphor she uh
yeah was like a no-hitter all right so
aubry and theo i'll toss uh i'll toss
this one to you now
what is something about john when you
guys first met and read the script that
made you think this right here is a
first-time feature director that i
should be taking a chance on right now
um look i'll be honest i'm very
suspicious of people especially
first-time directors i always look at
them like i don't know
i don't know if you can handle this but
um
john just i he just he lit he lived this
story he understood he understands this
movie on a level that
um nobody nobody does and i think
there's just something about everything
that john said it to me in those early
meetings was spot on we wanted it was
clear to me we wanted to make the same
exact film we had the same priorities
and um
he reminded me of like kyle mclaughlin
and twin peaks like just the the
confidence um almost like a robotic um
chilling confidence
that um i just
i couldn't get enough of and uh i just
um i just trusted him from the beginning
i just knew
i knew he had it i knew he was going to
do it and pull it off so
he did so
the robotic chilling confidence
that's something to aspire to
the compliment
that's
uh for me it was i it sounds
simplistic but the fact that we were
rehearsing because i got there
legitimately
i came right from atlanta doing this
other movie you know had to dye my hair
back to whatever color and then like i
didn't have much time but
the fact that he took the time
for us to rehearse and get to know each
other and it was us three in there
was
i i mean to me it's everything that made
the film you know what it is
people keep talking about like the
chemistry of it that started with the
rehearsal
and
the truth is the sad reality is you
never get it
you just don't get it even when people
have time they don't take the time and
the fact that john and aubry as the
producer wanted to do that was
everything
everything for what because it's you
know once you do these films it's you
got it's the team against the world
right to try to get it done
so that was the beginning of it so
thinking about them describing you as
confident john is making me think of
your director statement where you were
describing trying to be a filmmaker in a
way that filled you with fear
so i'm kind of curious to hear a little
bit about how you
applied that fear to you know you talk a
little bit about it in the uh the
statement about
funneling that into your script but then
also what happens when you hit set and
then get into post does that kind of use
of that fear have to evolve at those
stages of the process oh the fear never
ends man fear never stops clarified
right now we already made the movie
we're done with the movie and i keep
expecting the movie to fall apart i'm
like
man we just premiered but i'm afraid the
money might fall apart i don't know
about this
you encounter so many failures along the
way that by the time you have a success
you're so calloused that you
somehow can't absorb it it's like a war
veteran who comes home and like you
survived you lived and then you're
you're at the dinner table with your
family and you're still like in the war
you know and they're like dude you live
chill out that's like
it's just so hard to get a movie man
um
that but yeah in terms of like the fear
and forming the writing process i'm a
big believer in like every movie you
make is kind of a thesis about whatever
your life is at that moment i think
those typically create the best movies
uh and
at the time i was writing this there was
just a lot of uncertainty
and insecurity in my life i was trying
to get a career going and
it was tough and things were expensive
and i didn't have any money and i think
one of the big fears is that like the
more time i put in and to this career
was time that i was losing potentially
doing something else i was constantly
going uh do i want to put another six
months into trying to get this movie
made because that's six months i could
be studying for the lsat
and doing something that would pay off
in a much more predictable fashion
and i was scared that i'd end up you
know a middle-aged person suddenly
looking back on
what was all that time spent for you
know i could have done it
for something else that was the fear
um
i feel like that fear is probably very
relatable to a lot of people out there
i'm sure i'm sure it is it's funny
because wait a minute what's an lsat is
that how you become a lawyer
yes you got it aubry plaza yes let's do
that john come on
jesus but my point is
it's like an equal fear so like
playing it faith and not doing what you
love you know that's scary as well
because you could look back with regrets
in the same way so
it's i don't know damn if you do and if
you don't you're going to celebrate at
some point though right
we're at sundance right now look at this
yeah i hope the fear is in the rear view
mirror eventually because i feel like
you've earned it at this point in the
process i'm starting this funny
yesterday my girlfriend was like
at some point you're gonna have to start
like accepting that people like your
movie and then it's okay like that
that's gonna have to start at some point
yeah i'm working on it don't don't ever
accept this john the the most you know
successful people are the most miserable
don't ever forget that
sorry
february 27th
i'm sorry i don't know why i decided i
didn't mean to say that out loud
i'll throw the fear question your way as
well uh theo and aubry so you two have
so much experience but was there a
particular day on the shooting schedule
of this movie that you know it kind of
made you circle that day in red and say
to yourself that's the day that i'm
gonna be most nervous for
i will say the the and not to
you know give any spoilers or whatever
but there's a scene in the film where
emily gets robbed
and um
that day was very terrifying for me um
because i just knew
i knew i knew what was gonna happen and
we
one thing about this film that i just
still am so proud of is the cast
everybody
is so good in this movie
it doesn't matter if you they have one
line or if they're theo rossi everyone
is just
so good such such talented actors and um
i knew that the guy uh craig stark that
we cast as the guy that was gonna rob me
was real was real intense and real good
and i i just had a feeling it was gonna
it was gonna be hard and scary and i was
right
that was a very scary night for me it
felt very real and i had some i had to i
had a couple days after that to like
shake that one off but
that was that was a day that i
definitely you know circled in red
theo for what it's worth it's very
effective and sends the stakes soaring
through the roof yeah
i think any time that we got into a car
or a van i was like this could be
trouble because we didn't have the
luxury of like streets being closed down
or
it always felt we were
like the first thing i would ask is are
we moving on this one like are we so
we're gonna drive okay and you know john
would be like
in the middle of us and jeff would be
somewhere like
you're wearing him like a scarf and
you're like what is
okay we're doing this we're making we're
making this is happening and you just
have to go okay i'm just gonna keep
driving you don't know when you're gonna
turn there's nothing
so you just hoped
that those would
and they all did they all did so anytime
you're in a moving vehicle
i was like
i don't know if this is gonna make it
but it always did and it was great it's
very understandable just for fun because
i i play a would you rather game quite a
bit aubry and theo i i always ask the
silly question would you rather have to
fake drive in a scene or fake wake up in
a scene oh oh fake wake up for me i mean
yeah i i love i fall asleep easily like
two seconds honestly i will i'm going
fake drive i think i have so much dr
driving experience on camera that i
i think i got it down i mean you just
can't take your eyes off the road
people make that mistake actors make
that music
i
i'm into that
waking up is very hard for me because i
always feel
like everybody knows i wasn't asleep so
it's like that it's always hard for me
to be like
like i want
unless like i'm being woken up by like a
murderer or something it
i always feel like i failed at waking up
it always just feels like
don't overdo it is that how you wake up
in real life
you wake up i wake up in real life
talking to myself
whatever nightmare is happening pretty
much on the reg but
i'm always afraid i'm overdoing it when
i wake up it's a really good question
i'm gonna keep thinking about this i
could go on and on with those um
but i'm also very excited about how much
you're producing now but of course being
a producer can mean like a million and
one thing so aubry for you what does
working as a producer on a project mean
to you what do you strive to bring to
those films when you're filling that
particular role
well most of the things that i produce i
just hope that they get made first of
all because um they're
always like labor
of love for me and things that i just
feel so passionate about the things that
aren't necessarily like you know
um
easy to get made so just just getting
the movie off the grounds probably is
the number one thing and then for me
it's really just
when i read something that i
that i love and that i want to produce i
it's like i it's like i've seen it it's
like i've already done it it's like some
kind of
manifestation process for me where like
i read the scripts i see it all
and then i just want so badly to to
deliver on the the dream you know
version of that film and every that's
just in the back of my head all every
step of the way and mostly that is just
about who you're working with you know
putting together the right team of
people and collaborating with people
that
that you love to work with and that you
respect them
um so that's what i'm always trying to
do is just
meet my meet my people and
and just like i don't know try to just
do everything i can to like
to make that film that i first saw in my
head i appreciate that and i'm rooting
for you to keep at it too
theo
can you tell me about any conversations
you might have had with john about
nailing the right tone in this movie for
how yusuf approaches his work because
like i feel like i'm implicating myself
here but there's there's a really
surprising degree of warmth to the way
that he goes about it and you know i'm
sitting there thinking what would i do
in that situation and i feel like he
could convince me to commit a crime like
that
thanks yeah i mean that was that
yeah i'd like to convince people to
commit crimes um i try to do it all the
time i do with my kids i'm like steal
that take that gum don't you know we do
that at the supermarket just i just want
to keep them sharp at six and four to
see if they know how to steal um
no listen john knew the tone of the film
right away i mean and
we were always checking in it was always
us three kind of like huddling on every
little thing of the tone of it
so it's just sometimes when you have
like a shorthand
there's just like okay we're gonna try
this i mean we don't have a ton of takes
right so it's like we're going to try
and you're kind of there and
it was always a build to that moment of
when i see uh not not giving anything
away when i see her art in the apartment
of like
wait i have something too
right and that it kind of like
shifts
their relationship together and john
knew where all those beats were so a lot
of the work is done for you in in the
way of like what you're doing and again
i
this is why i love writer director so
much because there's no it's all there
it's all in there and then when you have
the star of the film producing it it's
like it's really all there you have
every component you know tyler's like in
right there but you know in it's all
there
you know and and jeff was right there
with us the dp so it's like there's the
the thing that it feels like the whole
movie is happening within these few
people
that's really
uh rare and unbelievable so the tones
are all there john just knew the whole
film he had the whole film in his head
which is great you feel it you feel it
while watching it i hate that i have to
let you guys go but i'll wind down with
this question that feels really unfair
john because you still apparently have
yet to celebrate how good this first
movie is would you ever consider making
an emily the criminal sequel
a gentleman never never never tells
fair
fair enough
fair enough yeah i can tell you this
much i love making the movie with all
these people
and
how can i not want to work with all
these
all these folks again you know
uh it was such a special experience for
me it was like one of the hardest things
i've ever done but also like the best
thing
i've ever done it was like a backpacking
trip like they're moments of misery but
then you get done with it and you're
like that was the best and you know
everyone so well and you're looking at
your pictures like you know like that
was
it was like that times a hundred like
that was the movie
so yeah would i make those people like i
would do anything with these folks again
you kidding
me for what it's worth you deliver a
very full and satisfying story but when
i get obsessed with something i tend to
get very greedy about it and i demand
more even if no one involved wants to
continue a particular story and they
want to do new things but
point being whatever all three of you
want to do next sign me up for it you
kick ass in this movie and i can't wait
to see more from you thanks so much
appreciate you thank you